minneapolis is in turmoil again this
morning after the latest police killing
in that city a massive car caravan of
protesters traveled through the city
last night stopping outside what is
believed to be the interim police
chief's home
22 year old amir lock was shot and
killed by a swat team during an early
morning no knock raid last wednesday the
officers were not even looking for him
now police video does show lock holding
a gun as an officer shot him our
national correspondent jerica duncan has
been following this investigation from
the beginning and joins us at the table
erica good morning good morning to you
good morning to everyone you know the
mayor jacob fry's office says it
severely limited the use of no knock
warrants last november as part of
reforms related to the death of george
floyd but a report from the minneapolis
star tribune found at least a dozen have
been issued since january locke's family
says the police startled locke while he
was sleeping and that he grabbed his gun
in self-defense we want to warn you the
video you're about to see is disturbing
a weekend of anguish in minneapolis
[Applause]
as thousands of protesters marched
through the city demanding justice for
22-year-old amir lock i would like to
see the police officers held accountable
first and foremost we need to end police
brutality and these no knock warrants
stop the lying body cam video shows a
minneapolis swat team executing a no
knock warrant after using a key to enter
the apartment multiple officers are
heard shouting with their guns drawn
as lock rises a gun can be seen in his
hand before officer mark hanneman shoots
him three times killing him it all
happens in about nine seconds locke's
name was not on the warrant and his
family says he was licensed to carry the
weapon and had no criminal record these
no not warrants have deadly consequences
for innocent black people family
attorney ben crump says no knock
warrants create unnecessary risks
you can knock on the door and announce
that hey the police we have a search
warrant so people when in the middle of
the night and while they're in slumber
here's somebody coming in their house
and then feel like they were being
burglarized
so far no charges have been filed in
lotte's death and officer honeman is on
administrative leave in a statement the
police officers association of minnesota
expressed sympathy for locke's family
and said no officer goes into a
dangerous setting like this wanting to
use a weapon that decision was not taken
lightly
obviously just hearing from the parents
on friday you know the mother saying she
never in a million years would have
imagined that she would be
one of the very people that she's
watched you know over over the years
people need to understand nationally
that no knock warrants that did not used
to be commonplace tactics from law
enforcement in the early 1980s only
about 1500 a year by the 21st century
more than 50 000 year by one estimate so
the question is did it need to explode
in that way is it still a useful term uh
uh tactic as frequently as it's being
used and that's you know the point ben
crump brought up too about it being
unnecessary and questioning yes if
there's another way which you talked
about talked about that last week it's
certainly the the last thing the
minneapolis police department needs at
this time and it does seem like they
need to reconsider those no knock
warrants and i understand that officer
doesn't want to burst in anywhere and
use his weapon but seeing both sides
neither does a man sleeping on the couch
and he was licensed to carry that gun
too yeah that's what his family is
unfortunate all the way around thank you
so much we appreciate you